اهلا بكم الى هذه المقابله الخاصه من
العربيه مع جيمسي وزير القوات المسلحه
البريطانيه ينضم الينا من البحرين اهلا بك
سيد هيبي ما هي اهميه التعاون الثنائي في
المجالين العسكري والدفاعين بين السعوديه
وبريطانيا وهذا الاتفاقيه التي وقعت في
الايام الماضيه
شكرا شكرا
المملكه
سمو الامير خالد بن سلمان
بريطانيا
كثيره عبرنا سنوات طويله ومجلات اخرى
تكنولوجيا الجديده التي نسائيه اليها ولكن
في ذلك هو رؤيه مشتركه
لانني
متطلباتها وكيف بامكاني السعوديه
وبريطانيا العمل من اجل تحقيقها ماذا يمكن
ان تقدم بريطانيا في هذا المجال التعاون
الدفاعي والعسكري خاصه على صعيد توطين
الصناعه العسكريه في السعوديه وهي من ابرز
اهداف النمو والتطور الحاصل في المملكه في
المملكه
بان هذه اولويه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
عبر التواصل عده وزراء مختلفين مع السمو
الامير همم
محمد بن سلمان وقال ان هذه هي الشراكه
التي تحقيقها ونحن في بريطانيا ورحم جدا
بذلك
او توسيع نموذج تعاون بين دوله مثل
بريطانيا
السعوديه
لا يمكن كل شيء في بريطانيا الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
العهد وهذا ما قاله الامير خالد بن سلمان
عندما زار لندن قبل اسبوع تقريبا العسكري
بريطانيا
والخليج عموما يعني اين وصل بماذا يتميز
هذا التعبد
كل ااه
الطويله الامد تجمعنا الصداقات قويه جدا
وتاريخ
ولكن
صالح بريطانيا
اولا لاننا نمره في مرحله
من الوقود الاحفوري الى الوقود المتجدده
خاصه بعد ان خروجنا من فتره حيث بريطانيا
وحلفاء ملتزمون جدا
مثلا بريطانيا وفرنسا وامريكا معهد لها
حضور كبير هنا المهم عندما ياتي شخص
بمناسبه لزيارته البحرين وغدا ساكون في
الكويت ان يعبر بوضوح ونقول باننا مهتمون
جدا في علاقتنا في الدول التي تعاون
الخليجي
والمحتمنا جدا بهذه المنطقه ااه مهما كنا
نسعى لتحويل اا مصادر الطاقه فعلا الواقع
هو اننا لن نتحول خلال سنوات العشره وحتى
20 القادمه وبالتالي ان الطاقه التي
تصدرونها من هذه المنطقه حيه عاملا رئيسي
بريطانيا
العراق التحدي
وكذلك المنافسين اخرين حول العالم لديهم
مصالحه هنا ونحن نرغب بيئتنا ضدهم
فانتقى هذه المنطقه منطقه هامه جدا من
العالم والخليج العربي او مجزعه الخليجين
وبريطانيا تجمعها مع علاقات طويله الامد
وانا اود ان اضمن ان يبقى هذا هو اساس كل
ما نقوم به هناك
في بريطانيا
من الممكن ان تخفض موازنتها الدفاعيه هل
سيؤثر ذلك على وجود قواتها في المنطقه اذا
حدث ذلك
عندنا قلق من اي خفض في موازنه الدفاعيه
رئيس الوزراء والمستشاره مؤخرا اكد انا
وزاره الدفاع الذي كل ما هي بحاجه اليها
لتحقيق برامجها الحاليه حتى مع التضخم
المتوقعه العام المالي القادم وان
المراجعه المكثفه التي ستاتي في شهر مارس
فان وزاره الدفاع تتوقع
اسهاماتها اوكرانيا
والهندي افريقيا
وعالميه معده
باحدث المعدات وانا متاكد من الرئيس
الوزراء والمستشار السيد اركاني ذلك خلال
تحقيق الموازنه بعد اشهر قليله تحدث عن
سلامه الملاحه البحريه هل هناك من تصور
مشترك مثلا مع دول الخليج للحفاظ على
سلامه الملاحه البحريه في المنطقه هنا
حول العالم
مختلفه حسب الدول في العتمه
اللي همم
شرعيه والقانوني وفي الدول الاخرى عمليات
القرصنه او تهريب المخدرات اما هنا مثلا
غالبا ما يقصد به
حراسات البحريه
اي خطا على الاطلاق لخفضيها بل على العكس
نحن فخروا جدا لما نقضيه هنا وندد ان نضمن
استبرارنا بذلك
الموضوع
الشحنه التي
احتجزتوها ولكن اريد ايضا ان اتوقف عن
سفينه اتش ام اس مونتروز لبريطانيه الى اي
حد تساهم وهي قادره على تامين هذه الملاحه
البحريه لدينا في المنطقه
همم هي همم
الشهر من الان وعدوا بامان همم
يرغبون بتقديم الشكر الىهم لكل العمل في
المنطقه
هنا ولكن
ستار وصلت الى البحرين همم وانا سعيد جدا
لان اراها
اليوم همم استبدل
البحار المتميزين همم
بالعوده الى الادله التي قدمتموها الى
الامم المتحده بعد احتجازكم شحنه محمله
بالسلاح كانت متجهه للحوثيين في يوليو
الماضي ماذا حصل بهذه الادله اين وصلت
التحقيقات
الى الامم المتحده من اجل مراجعتها واعتقد
ان هذا هو العمل الصحيح انه مهم جدا مهما
كانت قناعتنا بما نراه نحن همم
لابد ان لا يصادق عليها بشكل
مستقلته هنا فقط وجهه النظر نابل وجهه نظر
الامم المتحده ويكون رايها هو همم
الامم المتحده هي التي تكمل التحقيقات
وتوصل الى الاستنتاجات المناسبه ولكن كمان
نحن نؤمن بالله
والامم المتحده فهذا هو السبب صحيح
الايرانيه الى الحوثيين وهو الذي يؤجل
الصراع في اليمن
عايزين
الذي يعمل في المنطقه ومقام به بكل النجاح
خلال سنوات ترقيه الماضيه سيستمر واذا ما
استمر بواجبي فان هذه المحاولات الايرانيه
لدعم الحوثيين
سوف تتلاشى ولكن وكما نتوقع هنالك كثيرات
الاستخباراتيه
من اجل خفضي احتماليه
ولكن همم
اولاهم ان يعرف بها ان بريطانيا
والحلفاء الدائمه الااهبه الاستعداد لتقدي
مكافحه ابتكاراتنا لتقديمي عمل افضل ووقف
كافه هذه الشحنات وعرقلتهم
كيف تنظر بريطانيا الى الهدنه في اليمن ما
هي الجهود المبذوله للضغط على الحوثيين
للالتزام بها
النساء
الايراني
على هذه المقابله شكرا لكم